l'otan le café du centre a été un lieu
privilégié des ouvriers pour venir se
restaurer depuis quelques mois les
habitudes ont changé la pause de midi
est devenu plus informelle et pour les
restaurateurs les clients plus rares il
y en a au 1er confinement qui nous ont
clairement dit vous rouvrez au mois de
juin mais au mois de juin il fait
toujours aussi beau donc finalement on
va rester au sandwich pour le moment et
on reviendra peut-être quand il fera
froid ici 80 % de la clientèle sont des
ouvriers
ce midi ils ne seront que quelques uns
les autres préfèrent manger rapidement
ce qui leur permet de faire quelques
économies à la fin du mois la
propriétaire craint que certains ne
reviennent pas alors au bout de sept
mois de deux de pique nique au cul du
camion si je peux me permettre
oui je pense qu'ils vont garder ça
surtout qu'ils ont subi le confinement
en plein hiver et qu'ils ont fait donc
là je pense que ça va durer bonjour a vu
les loupiots au centre ville de vesoul
cette restauratrice rencontrent les
mêmes difficultés
la fréquentation de son établissement a
chuté à notamment à cause du télétravail
sont des clients qui règlent
essentiellement en tickets restaurant et
puis
on a à peu près 1500 euros de tickets
restaurant en moins par mois donc sur
une moyenne de 7 euros le ticket
restaurant vous pouvez chiffrer le
nombre de personnes qui manquent dans le
monde un changement de comportement que
les restaurateurs n'espère pas voir
durer le manger toujours dehors ou
manger un sandwich en permanence je sais
pas si c'est bien une bonne solution
donc on espère tous qui à un moment
donné on va revenir au naturel
on va revenir à il ya un an et demi en
arrière seule certitude pour le moment
s'il le faut les restaurateurs sont
prêts à de nouveaux s'adapter et à se
renouveler